who are the outside your close friend
group who are the greats to you top five
outside of my friend group so uh like
for me probably Norm Macdonald Mitch
Hedberg
George Carlin
Thompson number one oh yeah no
I wanted to say that it's an interesting
pairing No Mitch Hedberg David tell
David Patel David everybody deeply
respects David more than even his comedy
I love this show where he was uh
insomnia insomniac he's so good at just
the the natural comedy of human
interaction he's a brilliant comic he's
just a brilliant [__] mind
um Norm MacDonald's a [__] genius an
absolute genius I mean look you know
Chappelle and Bill Burr are are the two
best in our generation in my opinion and
that's you know and that's understanding
that like I'm still friends with some of
the best in our generation but like just
the way their brains work is really on
the next level like you know those are
guys Stan hope is the same way just
[__] genius you know I Rogan Segura
those are my friend group that's my
really close friend group but like those
other guys I'm friends with but they're
not like that's like
yeah Louis CK bro Louis CK [__] he's
amazing it's hard to do because you
start like forgetting the like people
and then it's almost like people go oh
so you didn't like that person you're
like no I [__] love that person yeah
yeah
I mean there's uh for me like Robin
Williams was a whole nother thing oh
yeah Sarah Silverman uh [__] uh I
love Janine I mean I'm a [__] big
Janine fan I love her brain Marin's
[__] hilarious you know uh Patton's
brilliant David Cross I mean there's
like it's you know it's really to ignore
those guys and those guys were like the
whole Forefront of the alternative
comedy front they're [__] amazing
yeah and the people that have like Marin
or Joe that have podcasts is interesting
it's an interesting pairing because you
get to know like everything about them
but then they're also Comedians and I've
gotten I've gone to Joe's Club a lot
listen Joe and just that whole group of
comics do comedy and go to the same set
over and over and over and to see how it
changes it's really cool it's the
coolest thing when I first started to
watch someone I could tell was really
brilliant at it because you'd watch him
Tinker with a set yeah and he'd he'd
have an idea like hitting someone over
the head with a hammer from behind and
then he'd work at nine different ways
you know and you'd be like whoa so
you're the hitting hammer in the head is
the thing that he's working on
I hope uh Eddie Murphy comes back
he's one of the greats Chris Rock Chris
Rock's [__] bring the pain is like
the reason I got into comedy yeah
do you have advice for Young Folks you
seem like a stellar example of a
successful human being
um or more seriously a very kind of
non-linear life idea of advice for young
people in high school and college I
don't have a a good life they can be
proud of don't worry too much
about what you do when you get older
but when you do start worrying
find the thing you love and it'll never
feel like work
to [__] I can't imagine what it must
feel like to be a lawyer and have to
read papers or whatever they do all day
and know that that's my day yeah I mean
it must feel like what I was school felt
like for me
if you find that thing you love to do
you will work endlessly effortlessly and
hard as [__] [__] every day and
you'll love every day of your life find
when you love and let it kill you
Bukowski said that for then that's the
[__] thing because that's what I'm
doing I'm letting it [__] take I'm
I'm [__] I'm I'm on that [__]
bullet train to [__] nowhere on this
[__] comedy journey I love it I love
it so it's like the Hunter S Thompson
thing what is it however you put it he
basically you're not supposed to be uh
end up in a well-preserved box you slide
it in sideways
smoke just beat up yeah just just a
giant mess I love I love those guys that
can really live that life that are like
yeah man I'm breaking it I'm breaking it
down like a guy like Tony Hawk or Matt
Hoffman who like yeah if I if I don't
[__] break the [__] out of this thing
before I I'm then I'm not doing it right
then again there's also Churchill who
tried to break the thing and he couldn't
lived into his 90s a bad [__]
just a bad [__]
so I guess the only hope we can have for
bird Chrysler is that you're going to be
the Winston Churchill of Comedy my life
has lived perfectly
if I'm 95 years old and All My Friends
Are Dead yeah yeah yeah
they're like they're like can you
believe that wolf got Rogan yeah can you
believe sagura 600 pounds and they had
to carry him out in a crane out of that
house
can you believe that it's just Burt
Chrysler and Joey Diaz laughing
just standing there in October October
just the two of you left just laughing
October is just I'm 95 at the Mark Twain
Awards and they're like Bert Chrysler's
still [__] here who saw that coming
I hope so Bert I'm a huge fan of yours
it meant so much to me when you said
that you knew who I was like we were
talking about it just it's so cool it's
so cool thank you for putting so much
joy and love out there in the world I'm
a huge fan and thank you for the love
you've got me thank you man I am a huge
fan of yours you keep doing you I'll
keep doing me and then let's see if we
can meet in the middle sometime having a
cold beer in the afternoon love you
brother love you